MILES. I'M CONFLICTED ON THIS
ON ONE HAND. THAT'S I LIKE
IT. WELL, I'M CONFLICTED ON
MANY THINGS BUT SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS ON ONE HAND. I LIKE
IT. WHEN A FOOTBALL
ORGANIZATION FOOTBALL COACH
WHOEVER ACKNOWLEDGES A
MISTAKE AND TRIES TO FIX IT
ON THE OTHER HAND.
IT WAS A PRETTY BIG MISTAKE
LAST YEAR AND THE COWBOYS
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE GETTING
INTO CHANGING UP THEIR
DEFENSIVE PHILOSOPHY WITHOUT
THE PERSONNEL NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT AND HIRING MIKE
NOLAN TO BE THE DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR WHEN THEY WERE
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR WHEN
THEY WERE PLENTY OF OTHER
CAPABLE CANDIDATES OUT THERE
GRANTED DAN QUINN HAD ANOTHER
JOB LAST YEAR. HE COULDN'T BE
HIRED BY THE COWBOYS TO BE
THE DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR. HE
WAS THE HEAD COACH OF THE
FALCONS, BUT STILL THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE MAKING SUCH
THE DEFENSIVE SIDE OF THE
BALL AFTER ONLY ONE YEAR OF
MIKE MCCARTHY IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
ORGANIZATION. IT'S AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO MCCARTHY. IT
SHOULDN'T HAVE GONE THIS
POORLY THIS QUICKLY AND IT
DOESN'T INSPIRE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE THAT IT'S
MAGICALLY GOING TO GET BETTER.
WELL, I THINK THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY THERE IS
CONFIDENCE THAT IT WILL GET
BETTER WOULD HAVE TO BE
BECAUSE OF THE GUY THAT THEY
HIRED TO BE THE DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR AND GRANTED DAMN
COINS DEFENSE HAS IN ATLANTA
WERE NEVER REALLY THAT
THAT GREAT. I MEAN EVEN THAT
TEAM THAT WENT TO THE SUPER
BOWL THAT DEFENSE WAS RANKED
IN THE 20S WITH BOTH IN TERMS
OF SCORING AND YARDAGE. SO
AND THEN ONLY THE YEAR AFTER
THAT WERE BOLD. THEY RANKED
IN THE TOP 10 FOR BOTH
YARDAGE AND SCORING IN TERMS
OF DEFENSE. SO YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK TO 2013 AND 2014 AND SAY
LOOK WHAT HE DID WHEN HE WAS
JUST THE DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR AND WHAT HE DID
WHEN HE WAS JUST IN CHARGE OF
THAT DEFENSE TO SAY YES. I
THINK DAN QUINN IS A GREAT
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR AND HE
COME IN AND HE CAN PLAY THAT
RULE. BUT LOOK, I DON'T KNOW
THAT YOU CAN GET MUCH WORSE
THAN WHAT MIKE NOLAN WAS
DOING LAST YEAR AND THE WAY
THAT THEY TRY TO TRANSITION
THAT DEFENSE AND FRANKLY. I
FEEL LIKE EVEN WHEN MIKE
NOLAN WAS HIRED PEOPLE HAD
SOME TREPIDATION AS TO WHAT
THEY THOUGHT MIKE NOLAN COULD
REALLY DO WITH THAT DEFENSE
GIVEN THE FACT THAT HE JUST
SAID NOT NECESSARILY BEEN A
VERY GOOD DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR IN LONG TIME.
RIGHT AND I'M MAKING THAT UP
WELL, NO AND AND LOOK THAT'S
THE THING AND WHEN A COACH IS
HIRED, SOMETIMES IT IS A
CHALLENGE TO GET THE
COORDINATORS YOU REALLY WANT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH AND
THIS MEANT. THIS ANSWER MAY
BE OUT THERE. MIKE MCCARTHY
HAD A WHOLE YEAR WHERE
CREATED THIS LITTLE
LABORATORY IN WISCONSIN WHERE
THEY WERE WORKING AND
PREPARING AND I DON'T KNOW IF
NOLAN WAS HIS FIRST CHOICE AS
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR FOR A
FULL YEAR OR NOT. I MAY HAVE
KNOWN THAT AT SOME POINT IF I
DID I'VE FORGOTTEN THE ANSWER
TO THAT BUT BACK TO DAN QUINN,
ONE OF THE DANGERS AND I LIKE
DAN QUINN AND HE DID A GREAT
JOB OVERALL WITH THE FALCONS,
BUT FOR THE 28 TO 3 COLLAPSE,
HE WOULD HAVE HAD A SUPER
BOWL CHAMPIONSHIP, BUT HE'S A
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR WHO
CAME FROM A TEAM THAT HAD TWO
DEFENSIVE SYSTEM THAT HAS
WORKED WITH MULTIPLE
COORDINATORS AND THE HEAD
COACH IS A DEFENSIVE
MASTERMIND. SO NOW YOU'VE GOT
DAN QUINN.
TAKING OVER THE DALLAS
DEFENSE WORKING FOR A COACH
WHO ISN'T A DEFENSIVE
MASTERMIND AS EVIDENCED BY
LAST SEASON YOU DELEGATE HALF
OF THE BOTTOM NEVER BEEN A
BIG FAN OF THAT OF DELEGATING
AN ENTIRE HALF OF THE BALL TO
A COORDINATOR WHEN YOU'RE THE
HEAD COACH AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S INVOLVEMENT BUT A LOT
OF THESE DEFENSIVE COACHES
HAND THE KEYS TO THE OFFICE
OF THE COORDINATOR LOT OF
COORDINATOR LOT OF OFFENSIVE
COACHES HAND THE KEYS TO THE
DEFENSE TO THE DEFENSE
COORDINATOR. SO OF THIS
IMAGE OF SEAN MCVEIGH HIS
FIRST YEAR WITH THE RAMS,
SITTING ON TOP OF A COOLER
MAPPING OUT PLAYS FOR THE
NEXT OFFENSIVE DRIVE WHILE
WADE PHILLIPS IS RUNNING THE
TEAM. SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THAT, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DELEGATE THE DEFENSE TO DAN
QUINN HAS HE EVER REALLY BEEN
A DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR YOU
COULD ARGUE. HE REALLY HASN'T
BEEN IN THE CLASSIC SENSE OF
BEING THE GUY WHO RAN THE
DEFENSE FOR AN OFFENSE OF
HEAD COACH THAT GIVES ME A
LITTLE BIT OF PAUSE AND AGAIN
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO MADE THE
DECISION THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
SAID ALL SORTS OF OPTIMISTIC
AND
COLORFUL FLOWERY THINGS ABOUT
LAST YEAR AND SHIRLEY DID WE
COULD PROBABLY DIG UP THE
QUOTES ABOUT HOW GOOD THE
DEFENSE WAS GOING TO BE AND
THAT THEY GOT IT WRONG. HOW
CAN WE HAVE FAITH THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET IT RIGHT
THIS YEAR WHEN THEY GOT IT.
SO WRONG LAST YEAR. WELL, I
MEAN IT'S MOSTLY BECAUSE YOU
HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE, RIGHT?
I MEAN THEY'RE IN THE NFC
EAST SO THAT'S ONE THING
THAT'S WORKING FOR THEM AT
THE VERY LEAST BECAUSE YOU
CAN AT LEAST LOOK AT SAY
WASHINGTON AND PHILADELPHIA
AND THE GIANTS AND SAY WELL
ARE THOSE THREE TEENS REALLY
GOING TO HAVE THAT MUCH OF
EXPLOSIVE OFFENSES? AND THOSE
THE TWO THOSE ARE THE THREE
TEAMS THAT YOU HAVE TO
PLAY TWICE A YEAR. SO I FEEL
LIKE IF THERE'S SOME OPTIMISM
IT WOULD BE BECAUSE OF THAT
WHAT DIVISION YOUR IN ALSO
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME PIECES
THAT ARE SO VERY TALENTED AT
LEAST MODERATELY TALENTED
THAT ARE ON THAT DALLAS
DEFENSE LIKE LAWRENCE. I MEAN,
THERE'S AN EDGE RUSHER. HE'S
BEEN VERY GOOD AT TIMES AND
NOT HAVE THE BEST SEASON IN
2020. BUT THEN AGAIN NOBODY
DID ON THAT DEFENSE VAN DER
ASH. WHAT A KIND OF HAPPENED
TO HIM LAST YEAR IS WELL,
HE'S SOMEBODY THAT IF YOU GET
HIM BACK INTO FORM AND
ESPECIALLY THE WAY HE LOOKED
AS A ROOKIE THEN MAYBE
YOU REALLY
SOMETHING THERE. SO I JUST
FEEL LIKE YEAH, I DON'T KNOW
THAT. I TRUST WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO EITHER IN THAT
IT'S ALL GOING TO WORK. BUT
AT LEAST THEY ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY ADMITTED
THEIR MISTAKE THEY CAN
CLEARLY SEE THAT THEY MADE A
MISTAKE AND NOW THEY'RE
TRYING TO RECTIFY IT AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET BETTER.
AGAIN, THAT'S WHY I'M
CONFLICTED. I GIVE THEM
CREDIT FOR RECOGNIZING THEIR
MISTAKE. I DON'T GIVE THEM
CREDIT FOR MAKING SUCH A
HORRENDOUS MISTAKE THAT WENT
OFF THE RAILS SO QUICKLY AND
OBVIOUSLY AND LET'S FACE IT
MODELS. THE TERMINATION OF
MIKE NOLAN WAS A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION THAT THE QUESTION
WAS. WERE THEY GOING TO DO IT
IN OCTOBER OR MAYBE SEPTEMBER.
THAT'S HOW BAD IT WAS RIGHT
OUT OF THE GATES. SO THEY GOT
IT WRONG. THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET IT RIGHT BUT THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO GOT IT WRONG OR
THE ONES WHO ARE MAKING THE
DECISION THIS TIME AROUND IN
AN EFFORT TO
IT RIGHT AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT MCCARTHY IS ON THE HOT
SEAT. JERRY JONES DOESN'T
LIKE TO ADMIT THAT HE HAS
MADE MISTAKES IN A
SIGNIFICANT AND DRAMATIC WAY
AND EVEN THOUGH HE'S GOT TONS
OF MONEY. HE'S NOT A BIG FAN
OF PAYING BUYOUTS. SO I THINK
MCCARTHY IS SAFE NO MATTER
WHAT BUT AT THE SAME TIME
MCCARTHY'S SUPER BOWL WIN FROM
2010 MAY AS WELL BE FROM
1910 GIVEN THE WAY THAT HIS
TEAMS HAVE PLAYED IN.
N'T YEARS OF HIS COACHING
CAREER UP TO THE POINT WHERE
HE WAS FIRED BY THE PACKERS
WITH A MONTH LEFT IN THE
SEASON AND IN 2020 HIS FIRST
YEAR WITH THE DALLAS COWBOYS.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT GOES OPEN
MIND AND WE'LL SEE NEW
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR AND
THE PROOF WILL BE IN HOW MANY
POINTS THE OPPONENT'S SCORE  GA